to welcome everybody to an extremely
ordinary episode of the h3 podcast thank
you to candid quipped hems and door -
for sponsoring today's episode I was
expecting ela to be here today but I
don't quite see her in her seat hmm Oh
what is that is that American music
that's weird that's coincident cos ela
just passed her citizen test yesterday
ela just became an American citizen is
that mobility Mary what is happening oh
[Music]
my goodness ela are you here oh wow oh
my god welcome
ela a tango guest today she left last
time as an Israeli she enters today as
an American ela how does it feel talk to
me tell me how did it feel to read the
Gatsby and all the to glory
tell me of you like now I can really
write it you know I got the flags and
the balloons like I feel like every old
person on a mobility scooter they always
have this like personalized write
attached to it
absolutely now we got ours right we're
all well and the red of the Gatsby
matches perfectly I mean wow I feel
worthy to be writing it now as an
American well yellow uh we've got more
surprises for you today you know when
you when you pass the citizen test you
do a oh ceremony when you pledge
allegiance well we have an an oath
ceremony of our own here at the HP
podcast now I'm gonna have to ask you to
join us back in the main lobby you're
gonna have to back this thing up no meet
you
okay let's gonna back it up here try to
capture this Dan cuz this gonna be
sloppy oh I'm sorry I just ate my words
you lose got it the manoeuvre so you're
coming back towards Dan okay all right
okay all right all right
we do have workers comp so it's fine
well you're cold on Pook for it go
forward you're on condensed cable okay
great
okay come back now go ahead and show
what we have here cue the music Zach now
what we have here is this god damn god
damn Oh sama
let me is the music playing okay yet let
me hear that I gotta get an American
spirit god damn bow sama I tell you what
the sama damn come damn take them
terrorists down man now we got to have
Gatsby in that goddamn eel American
citizen Ming god damn of salmon so today
Europe we have the Gatsby the American
vehicle of choice it's like Ford of
mobility scooters we have Osama here in
what coincidentally looks like a twin
tower that was not by design dancing no
that wasn't by design damn it's just
boxes on top of each other because that
would mean you're taking down the tower
and that's not American yeah we're
taking out a salmon ELA before you take
out Osama here do you have any words for
the troops to Osama bin Laden his sons
who are still out there or Isis at large
do you have anything to say as a as an
American citizen something for our
troops that's right that's the only
correct answer and to the terrorists out
there that threaten you a pledge to
uphold the Constitution and all of its
enemies do you have anything to say to
the enemies of the Constitution I did
pledge that I will serve the United
States if needed
watch out this is a need I think and I
think today you're about to make good on
that pledge
so ela it is with great pleasure I
present to you the burning of a sama via
Gatsby ela [ __ ] him up
[ __ ] that terrorists come back up back
up back up over that get that bloodlust
going you up let's bomb some butterflies
[Music]
that's good right all right all right
yeah now you're scaring me try to catch
me dude
now you're scaring me dude we're on the
same side huh all right that's a gun
expected to it
well you actually have a mind yes what
should we do at this mic'd and turn it
off
dancing well congratulations that was a
lot of fun was that
thank you like me though we're both
American mobility our spirit before you
got on that thing you were like I don't
want to hit the table setting and I
found myself when I was going to trying
to [ __ ] with Danny and like you charged
at him but you actually came at me I did
jump on the table and I was a little
scary I never I never shaved you guys
that close did I down yeah you know
pretty good one boy well that's the
Gatsby and that's why we have workers
comp so not a problem I wanted to test
you guys all you members of our cast
here the h3 nation ela had to take a
civics test there's a hundred questions
on civics that you have to know so I
picked 20 of the choice questions out of
100 I'm gonna quiz you guys and I want
to see what the [ __ ] y'all were talking
[ __ ] like oh I'm a genius
to be fair they all 80 of them are like
stupid obvious also they asked me like
the easiest ones on the test how many
states are there she like that not even
like who's the president right now they
asked you that that was Rhonda what they
aren't even trying who's the president
right now yeah imagine getting that
wrong I don't know is it cool okay who's
the president right now yeah George
Washington do you remember any other
ones they asked you
[Music]
one was about let me say if it's one of
the questions who was the president
during the it's not the Great Depression
and World War two it was a little spicy
yeah okay so I've got you guys ready
back there yeah okay first question how
many amendments does the Constitution
have we got to see you guys go ahead I
get just you want anybody to jump
anybody jump in I think I wanna see [ __ ]
23 okay you you guys are wrong you guys
are all wrong 27 27 hansol okay whatever
we're over 27 yeah Dan yeah and you guys
speak up cuz you know we got it you
gotta expose yourself to hear true okay
you all three have to answer at the same
time in you know five seconds the idea
of self-government is the first three
words of the Constitution what are these
three words We the People what are two
rights in the Declaration of
Independence life and liberty free
speech I need a name a California State
Senator Dianne Feinstein look at you you
guys come together you guys came
together
how many house how many representatives
are in the House of Representatives one
hundred hundred what the [ __ ] Zach hit
hit him with a man definitely not oh you
know I actually do know this one
it's time it's 438 is that right Louis
but it's 435 it changes based on states
get more or less depending on the
population oh I was you know what I was
I was confusing it with the electors
it's 538 for the cover track honestly it
if the president the vice president
cannot serve then who becomes president
the speaker the house
Ian this one's for you because you're
quiet how many justices are on the
Supreme Court nine who's the chief
justice
Ian of the supported again well you're
the supreme court expert apparently
Cavanaugh isn't it Robert that's Roberts
I told when I was trying to help either
remember that I said think of the white
under the Constitution this one's for
Zach what powers belong to the federal
government what powers you can name one
[Music]
head hit that time clock wanna know the
true answer is to print money and I
thought and make treaties make treaties
but the president is the only one that
can declare war
that's the executive know that Congress
you're wrong okay and that's like a
hundred years that's been a little
questionable well there you go
thank you I do like I did like your
first answer of marijuana this one's for
Dan I don't dance dan knows the [ __ ]
okay one under the Constitution what
powers belong to the state good Dan and
it I'll give you a hint
it is marijuana what powers belong to
the state yeah yeah all the powers not
articulated in the Constitution or well
that's a really poor answer well I mean
technically
no there's powers in the Constitution
that belong to the state one of them is
to issue a license Oh another to provide
education security another is to provide
security thing Leila police poll is are
those specifically articulated though
according to the flashcards we use under
the Constitution those powers belong to
the state that I mean that is I mean
dude I've got flashcards they were pre
they're pre-printed okay in no this
one's for Zach who is the Governor of
California
Gavin news new something that's close
enough okay
Ian who is your state representative if
you know this I'm gonna give you I got a
I got a do something nice for you if he
knows this I'm sorry I don't know or
anyone anyone Adam Schiff are you
serious where do you know yes
I thought they this guy was the whole
Burbank I wonder if they have a
different representatives in our minds
brad Sherman no I did you vote for brad
Sherman yeah yeah why is that who is the
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi Ian
what when is the last day you can send
in your federal income tax forms April
20th April 5th tardy tardy is what the
federal government and so students in
another 20th
[Music]
[Applause]
it's April 15th isn't that right Zach
congratulations Ian why did the
colonists fight the British the Brits
all sorts of [ __ ] their teeth it was it
was because they were living in their
houses they had no self-government
and they were paying high taxes that's
right with no representation exactly in
okay then because they call soccer
football I had got the distance
themselves in who wrote the Declaration
of Independence wait why you [ __ ] try
to goof on me and now who wrote the
Declaration of Independence jae-in
what's the Declaration of Independence
adopted he in I'm gonna phone a friend
and pass it along 1776 wrong okay this
one's for oh this one is for each one of
you name three different of the original
13 States the name not just three I'll
name the best three good Massachusetts
New York Pennsylvania
go ahead sac Delaware Virginia and are
we going with Virginia yellow and
remember that is correct and and and get
hidden in and name the other eight
[Laughter]
Hawaii hmm okay let's let's move it
along
what name one u.s. territory Zach Puerto
Rico okay let's move on congratulations
we're also to say how many amendments
there's the [ __ ] lot of a comment
you know yeah and there's been repeals
there who could keep track of all that
[ __ ] exactly now I want to announce
right now
do I have to the folder with all the
photos of the rip and dip where is that
ela it's in Google Drive and The Shard
drives Jesus go ahead and talk about the
meetup as I polish alright so tonight we
are flying to New York which I cannot
believe we didn't pack yet and we are
gonna be there on Friday at the meet and
greet the rip and a pop-up shop do we
have the info yes we do it the info is
okay thank you
rip and Devin meet-and-greet me either
are gonna be in New York City this
Friday
Beibei in Manhattan we're doing a pop-up
store there in collaboration with rip
and dip we have another collab that was
extremely popular and exciting from last
year we're doing it again this year
bigger and better than ever the address
which we'll put in the description is
107 Grand Street New York New York Bay
Bay you don't need the zip 100 1 3 it's
Manhattan what do you get it huh 103
Grand Street that's all you need to know
let me show how I know 7 107 I guess I
should say it right I'm gonna hit it so
here we go the sick here's we got the
hoodie we got the camo pants we got the
plush everything you see is for sale
except the big ones if the big one we
got the loved the cat and bear cut up is
so sick hoodie we got the whole thing we
got the rug that's not for you guys
that's for us we got the camel what we
got the socks hold the phone we got the
slippers oh god oh no
hold the phone slippers the t-shirt oh
my god the plush doll oh the slippers
who's gonna cop those everybody right oh
my goodness it's all happening on the
bottom you got the rip in depth Eddie
fresh
the shirt oh Jesus oh they're hiding in
the pocket [ __ ] me you've got this shirt
you got this puffy jacket you've got the
windbreaker hold the [ __ ] breaker
turns into that it turns into a frickin
fanny pack case you want to carry I
frankly can't ever see anyone doing that
but maybe maybe if you're looking maybe
do you see do you see that ever being a
thing maybe I mean I do hate carrying
and jacket with me but it's not like a
functional fanny pack but it's better
than like holding it right there you go
so you can do that but you don't have to
either it's just enough yeah and breaker
there you go you got the long sleeve
dude you got the Hat this jacket [ __ ]
rules are you serious right now look at
these two cool dudes ah the beanie
forgot about oh yeah this long-sleeve
mm-hmm we got a lot of stuff this
jackets so sick huge chenille patch
right mm-hmm corridor in a corduroy
jacket there's those got the you there I
mean it's and we're gonna be there in
person for four hours I mean we're gonna
try to go longer we're gonna try to go
as long as we can but I just those
things are very what's the word it's
very hard work it's hard it's exhausting
it's a lot it is because each person
that you meet it's like you want to give
them girl yeah but anyway we'll be there
for at least 11 if not 11 to 3 sorry
we'll be there for at least 4 hours
we're meeting jontron that night for an
easy meal I'm happy to announce to
everybody as well what you are all not
invited to mm-hmm we simply don't have
enough seats at the table but I'd love
to take you all with me
so everything will also be available on
the roof in the website yes and in their
stores in LA and Japan they have a store
in Japan which nobody isn't in Japan but
if you're in Japan it's there so there
you go guys we're excited we'll see you
guys in New York this Friday
details are in this script
and exciting stuff now Zack we got so
much to get to my goodness
Zacks birthday we're gonna miss because
we're not doing a Friday episode because
uh we're not here so we wanted to honor
Zack our sound lad of one year he's
really blossomed he's really grown he's
served us laughs goofs and unforgettable
moments of eating mayonnaise and horsey
sauce you got any mail we do that thank
you for asking
yeah Zack should duck join us in here
Dan what do you think yes I guess so dad
please join us today it is his birthday
and we also recently realized he's been
with us one year yeah I did say that you
did say that it wasn't sure if you said
it as like a birthday thing or is that
okay oh did we celebrate his birthday
when he joined you're saying Zack come
in here we got a celebration for you I
don't know I mixed it up yeah sit sit
join us I've got questions and I've got
celebrations and I've got so many things
to honor you with here today so well
just wait so Zack how was it been you've
been here for one year it's your
birthday tell us about yourself ah it's
been amazing absolutely amazing and am i
how like tell me about how good of a
boss I am thank you the best that's not
and okay great we've covered all that
first of all we have a present to honor
by all means yes absolutely
this is from everyone in the game we put
we pitched all in together you get
something really special so we are sure
you're gonna enjoy it and let's see
what's inside
it's a shoved inside of a Dollar Shave
but I assure you it's not a razor
[Music]
can we get oh yeah I'm asking for sound
bites but our sound guys like it like a
drum roll or some
so describe what you see oh no way yeah
hundred dollars the RV's with a bunch of
horsey sauce the guy likes horsey sauce
we deliver am I wrong
yeah in horses thank you so much you go
to prison that's probably currency hey
can I eat one now so we got $100 of gift
card star bees know your favorite
restaurant
so much absolutely and there's probably
I don't know five hundred packets of and
tell us about your journey due to
obscure yeah I said to the lady give me
as much horsey sauce as you're
authorized that was a good line how did
they how did she react to that she was
very game she didn't ask a single
question she's probably seen weirder
[ __ ] she's like yeah no no worries
check out our office to dining in over
yeah you guys really outdid yourselves a
can or not Zack had nothing to hide dan
and Ian really uh round of applause for
making this a special day for everybody
now let's act go ahead and I see you've
got a horsey all queued up I did not ask
for this but you again you've served the
show and uh we appreciate you so much so
Zack hitting that horsey sauce now you
have to do all of these okay well here
we go the fun is just beginning so take
this this is yours we have more to honor
us go ahead put that down and then
there's a plate on your seat was there
played on your seat not okay go ahead
sit down Dan bring in the cake we have a
specialty cake that we made just for you
oh yeah we bake this or so it's
specialty
we made and bring in space got it it's a
cake instead of an icing mayonnaise it's
covered in mayonnaise like Ann tell us
about this cake as dan prepares it oh
damn that's cold-blooded
[Laughter]
oh wait dude Ian is that Manny's in the
middle is it actually no it's from Ian's
bakery that's mail right
yeah and that looks like a masterpiece
yo I can't believe you actually put mail
in the center cut of the cake dude
that's next level I mean seriously Dan
Danny puke yeah dan what do I got it you
have an early signs that it's showing on
the screen den what do I got to do to
get you to come take a bite of this
really come on come on your one bite you
can take a bite now a party bro if I pay
you two grand you're gonna have to eat
that whole slice
I didn't [ __ ] it off Danny sure are in
yeah the smell is pretty overwhelming
get us out of that Ian did you uh it's
in my Copen huh yeah so tell us about
this oh my god tell us about this cake
it was disc Ameen I just bought well I
bought the layers I didn't bake them cuz
I didn't think anyone would eat it yeah
well yeah but I asked a woman just for
two loaves with no icing and she was so
Confucius like wait you don't want me
and I'm like no we're gonna do it
ourselves and she looked and all I had
in my car was four jars of mayonnaise
please give me that like the good brand
not like the Kroger [ __ ] oh this is top
talk to you come on we this we we make
we make this with love what else did you
put in it it's all mayonnaise that's it
now you experimented with middle layers
mayonnaise yeah now you experimented
with trying to thicken the male right I
tried it was it was too tough too
nothing is better than the real thing
well is that we honor you today on your
23rd birthdays all right 20 seconds 20
so young man your stomach should handle
that yeah you know last time I haven't
eaten mayonnaise since when I ate all
that mayo it I literally puke straight
mayonnaise for the whole week I'm not
even cute like it was straight [ __ ]
[Laughter]
wonder what the Guinness record lady
what her like [ __ ] and puke looks like
cuz I had to puke it was just white and
chunky and I was puking from the taste
of the mayonnaise make you puke more it
made me puke my I would rather throw a
balcony day well I can you get a shot of
the managed sliding down the side of
that I'm gonna tell you I'm not confess
that the smell is quite getting to me at
this moment
dang be a good sport tell me your damn
Ian the Baker doesn't want to taste this
cake what Baker doesn't taste his own
that's true I just decorated I don't eat
it all right well are you special pie
why don't you go ahead and take a bite
and I'll think about taking a bite okay
if you want I mean you know we can't
force you to do anything but I noticed
you took one with a lot of cake you want
some horsey on top of that it looks real
I mean it looks like the real deal if I
just saw you bite and not I'd be like
yeah that looks like bone that looks
like a ball mask cake happy birthday
Zack we appreciate everything not bad I
thought you were gonna say not bad
hmm oh my god
dad's not looking too hot vacuum switch
to Dan for chrissake can you split
screen so you can watch me taking a bite
and Dan at the same damn watch this
clothes got to get a bunch of frosting
on there do it just do it
touch your tongue have regrets I've been
a band-aid off let's do it oh it's like
those flavors don't marry the sweetness
helps
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh it's rural America wait but you gotta
get frosting there's a lot of pricing
here take now okay yeah no you're right
uh my honor your I honor your service
go ahead Elona watching
salute the troops thank you for your
service I'm proud of you Joe dan for a
minute I want to see Dan's face up Dan
is really suffering
Joey let's show you look well show Dan
good job that was awful I'm proud as
hell of you I can't believe you took a
dip that's different when you become an
American citizen well Zach you have any
words for uh thank you you're welcome
absolutely I'm loving working here and
it's an honor to be a part of this and
yeah thank you thank you that by the way
that we have a real cake to wear after
this is reborn to watch people you cake
Cheers
hey hey Cheers Zach we honor you we
think you lost something into a
fantastic young man thank you
the potential is limitless I see when I
see you shoveling Manny's into your
mouth I think there's a guy that cares
about the show unlike these other two
foods back there
I was elbows deep in mayonnaise oh
really
you didn't need it though it was
permeating yeah well thank you that's
true in that is true you guys both put
in a lot of work I appreciate that but
ultimately when we're live that's what
counts
yeah and zach is the king so guys so you
want to take that on your way out
you might take that home you want let me
know we got to go to break anyways Oh
got about break just 33 okay let's throw
it to break we're gonna clamp this
mayonnaise situation and we'll be right
back with all the great scoops top
stories and the top gaffes and all the
laughs you could ever expect from this
show a free podcast we will be right
back
are you losing your hair do you want to
keep that hair on your head you're
beautiful and gosh darn it you deserve
to have a big beautiful head of hair
that's why him is riding on on his
chariot with a bag full of hair to tape
to your head they actually have more
elegant solutions than that we got to
prevent that hair loss before it starts
because we got to keep those precious
locks where they belong on your freaking
head so here's what we're gonna do about
it
for hems calm a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care and sexual wellness for
men thanks to science
we can keep the beautiful locks on your
head where they belong this is
prescriptions backed by science hims was
created by guys who know that some men's
health conversations are easier online
than in person there's no more awkward
in-person talk their visits or long
pharmacy waits for hims connects you
with real doctors online which is going
to save you hours and hundreds of
dollars it's completely confidential
discreet you answer a few quick
questions a doctor a real doctor will
review and if they terminates right for
you they can prescribe you the medicine
you need to keep the hair on your head
prevent hair loss and is shipped
directly to your door this is the real
deal this is prescription back to
sciences keep that beautiful hair on
your friggin head order right now my
listeners can get started with hims a
complete haircut for just five dollars
today right freaking now while supplies
last and subject to doctor's approval of
course see the website for full details
and safety information this will cost
you hundreds if you went to a doctor of
pharmacy somewhere else so go to for him
home slash h3 that's fo r hims com / H
sleeve for hims cop / h3
holidays are coming back you want a big
beautiful smile because everyone's will
be taking your picture and you need your
teeth on point okay now if your teeth
aren't straight and perfect they're not
holiday season you're gonna have to look
at your ugly mug every frickin time that
family photo comes up and let's be frank
that's just gonna throw you into a deep
and let's despair depression that you're
only gonna get to climb out of till next
season we got to stop something right in
the path that's why I want to talk to
you guys about candid candid as candids
aligners can help straighten your teeth
faster than traditional wire braces
treatment takes only six months on
average an experienced orthodontist who
is licensed in your state creates a
custom treatment plan then they show you
a 3d preview so you can see how your
teeth will look after they're done
candids aligners are comfortable
removable and completely invisible
candid ships your liners directly to you
and there's no hassle of going into an
orthodontist office and let's be frank
here guys let's be candid if you will
cost sixty five percent less than braces
holy crap I wish I had this when I was a
kid braces are the worst
and with each aligner purchase canted
donates $25 to smile trained who brings
safe 100% free cleft lip and palate
treatment to children around the globe
let's be frank I mean who cares about
that I'm getting that is very nice
that's very nice of them call to action
get your photo ready smile by the
holidays go to candid c/o candid co.com
slash h3 and use code h3 to get $75 off
holy crap that's candid co.com slash h3
code h3 for $75 off candid c/o calm
slash h3 cottage they god bless america
it's back to school that means it's time
to take care of those teeth those gums
that's disgusting breath so that when
you're talking to the cuties boy or girl
whatever you're into they're gonna want
to grab you by the neck and thrust their
face into your face and kiss you and
then from there who knows but your
beauty whatever happens you want your
breath to be spot-on that's why I
introduce the only toothbrush will ever
enter my mouth quip okay Dan do you use
quip I do actually
exactly damn we didn't have a quip in
the office because somebody jacked them
all but they're like solid gold we don't
know where they went
I bet Dan's like I'll bring in my own I
was like Dan I'm not gonna break make
you bring in your quip
you guys know Equipe is it's an electric
toothbrush it kicks ass it chews
bubblegum and it has hit a grand slam
every time it's been at that the quip
electric toothbrush it vibrates okay
it's a little pulsating tube it's on
power vibration style as a $200
mainstream brand it pulsates and it
tells you when to switch quadrants in
your mouth to make sure you're getting
an even brush and make sure you're
brushing for long enough so it tells you
when to stop and it tells you when to
switch quadrants is that these soft
rubbery bristles that are just heaven
they don't harm my gums I'm telling you
when I use other toothbrushes it [ __ ]
my gums up it really does and the gums
they don't grow back they recede when
you brush too harshly
these have this very unique rubber
bristles that I finally frankly find to
be a delight it's it's as good as it
gets
I mean really you got no reason not to
not to just give clip a shot it's
perfect for getting back into them the
morning routine it starts - just $25 and
if you've got a get quip comm slash h3
right now you can get your first refill
pack for free give it a shot it's 25 but
I'm telling you just put this thing in
your mouth and you're gonna be like oh
god that's your first refill pack free
at GE TQ UIP comp slash h3
let's cut the BS okay I've got a door -
ed in front of me and I'm gonna go
straight to the bottom cuz this is the
best part okay if you go to a door - app
it's a food delivery service you get
five dollars off your first order of $15
or more when you download the door - app
and enter promo code h35 three dollars
any meal of any of your favorite places
I'm talking about
three hundred and forty thousand
restaurants in 3300 cities I'm talking
about door-to-door delivery in all 50
states and canada order from your local
goat Tues or choose from your favorite
national restaurants like Chipotle
Wendy's chick-fil-a and the Cheesecake
Factory what about Popeyes didn't
include Popeyes includes chick-fil-a
come on what is this you guys don't need
to worry about dinner you're gonna let
dinner come to you with door - you don't
want to cook you just want to pamper
yourself and that's what I'm talking
about you get five dollars for freaking
free on them right now our listeners
five dollars off the first order of $15
or more when you download the door - app
and enter promo code h3 my dudes don't
forget that sperm will code h3 for five
dollars off your first order from door -
we're back we've celebrated and now it's
time to get serious the talk of the town
Saturday Night Live cast member fired
for racial slurs Shane Gillis a comedian
I never heard of it was announced that
he was hired to Saturday Night Live
alongside I guess the first age that can
be true the first Asian comedian on SNL
first Asian yeah
they never hired a Asian I found that
hard to believe too but if that's the
same reporter parently not and I can't
think of a single cast member who's
Asian so well congratulations - they
aged - the Asian community they made it
but so at the literally the exact moment
that they announced this guy Shane
Gillis is hiring almost like - within
two hours
people started combing through his
material and they're like oh well he's
he's a racist he said racist joke so
what I would like to do here today is
get out the the judge I would like to
get out the gavel put on the powdered
wigs and take a stand on the h3 jury
this is the agency judgment and this is
when we pass judgment on these
controversial issues and I'm not gonna
sit on the fence I'm gonna weigh in I'm
gonna give you my true opinion on this
I'm gonna take a deep dive and we're
gonna pass judgment on this man
Shane Gillis I shall pass judgment and
the judgment shall stand and it shall be
decreed the law and therefore the
correct opinion welcome to Judge Ethan
we gotta get some [ __ ] like that cuz
it's all wait I feel like
[Music]
welcome to Judge Ethan the only judge
who's got a blood pressure higher than
his IQ I don't know what pressure
numbers are jersey 'then he weighs in on
controversial subjects to make sure to
divide his fan base and upset everybody
judge ethan just when you thought judge
shows couldn't get any more interesting
judge ethan breaks down the wall like
the kool-aid man on the gatsby and he
says uh uh to all the haters that's
right judge ethan has never been accused
of sexual misconduct yes judge ethan has
never sexually assaulted and an employee
that's known that we know about judge
ethan has never shown his penis to coeds
at least that we know about and most of
all judge Easton is a wholesome god
bless america with an American wife
and he is qualified to pass judgment on
any man or woman it's part of the
correct opinions on this is the correct
opinions own judge Ethan take all soul
all rise for judge Ethan should I keep
going
no Zack Zack sponsible you hit me with
that music that the Spirit of Christ
compelled me you did bring up something
interesting for me like the way you were
saying that you haven't sexually
assaulted anyone mm-hmm like I wonder if
that's kind of becoming a part of like
hiring someone on the resume just kind
of denial accusation yeah no accusation
so far I mean anyone yeah so far I mean
who was it that said this I think was
Chapelle he was like and it's new
special yeah I mean I don't think I did
anything but we'll see perfect yeah
we'll see I think I'm fine but let's
talk about Shane let's let's talk about
Shane okay so they announced on Thursday
and with two hours a video from 2018
surfaced and what you used a racial slur
specifically against Asians used the
word [ __ ] now I'm allowed to say [ __ ]
for some reason that's fine and the rep
see I'm not I would never use that to
refer to someone but in the in the
context of a conversation about it I
feel comfortable saying [ __ ] son does
YouTube probably but you can't do that
with the n-word you know what I mean
like I can't use the n-word in the
conversation of the n-word sure I got in
trouble for that yeah but I'm gonna say
[ __ ] and how I said that's okay I mean
are you do you know that I feel that
it's less severe I do I feel like it's
less severe and I and I'm just these are
my feelings I mean you guys surely agree
with me back there I mean oh my god we
see when we got deimata to be honest
forget about the amounts I've talked
about social norms yeah I mean in the
scale of racial slurs I suppose that one
but I don't even is that fair I mean I
guess it doesn't have the n-word has a
lot more of a loaded history
exactly that is true yes yes I don't
know what's the point is it I personally
don't even know that word so I have no
cure nowadays I hadn't heard it in a
long time it's like all the good ones
you know there's one for everyone
everyone's got one and we're for the
four black people is is like SKS tear
racial slur and then like I would say F
tear racial slurs like what is the one
for the Irish people like Patti Mick a
Mick it's like well who cares that's an
F T racial slur I would ever think a
[ __ ] is probably like that's right below
the N word that's like a h-here slur
right Dan yeah we should totally do a
power I was gonna ask you what you where
you would rate the K word yeah it's high
I mean that [ __ ] is packing with a lot
of heat yeah like you don't say that
unless you really [ __ ] hate Jews yeah
you know what I mean yeah yeah so that's
a good that's a powerful one for sure
but nothing can uh
nothing can deem out the the n-word what
about Fredo Fredo Fredo as we all know
it's number last year I can't believe
you even said that oh they're banned all
right well here here's what he said okay
podcast from last year let's take a look
talk about town and he says let the you
know let him live there come on ously
he's like doing what I would have tore
that as is erase what a racist person
would say like oh what the mm-hmm let
him let the other people live there
right obviously an attempt at humor I
don't find it particularly I mean I
don't think that's enough to cancel
somebody over but it goes deeper we
unveil more let's see what this this
video is not available
all right our research is over that's
all we have no I'm kidding we got a lot
more so he issued a statement this was
this that was the clip that went viral
he issued a statement he said I'm a
comedian who pushes boundaries I
sometimes miss if you go through my ten
years of comedy most of it bad you're
gonna find a lot of bad missus I'm happy
to apologize to anyone who's actually
offended by anything I've said my
intention has never hurt anyone but I am
trying to be the best comedian I can be
and sometimes that requires risks you
know that's a fair point and I have to
say I saw I actually saw Rob Schneider
tweet about this and I I will agree that
Rob Schneider I hate to say it made a
good point
what he said all the people who are
talking [ __ ] and wanting to cancel
comedians would never have the balls to
go bomb onstage or something you know
it's like you he's right you got to take
risks and sometimes you don't know where
the boundary is and at maturity or an
experienced iPhone victim - that myself
here on this show and I've grown a lot
wiser and I've learned a lot more about
where the boundary of funny is and and
socially responsible and just looking
like a [ __ ] idiot
are and you got to throw yourself in the
mix to learn those things and so it's
really it's just it's not fair to judge
people that they're especially someone
who's a entertainer and comedian who is
figuring out where those boundaries are
and stuff because it's all recorded and
like forever right available for
everyone so so this guy I mean it was it
was almost I mean it was hilariously
like I mean it was like an epic thing
where he two hours it's kind of what
happened to Kevin Hart like this guy's
yeah we're celebrating him oh [ __ ] this
guy in two hours and SNL fired him yeah
so we go we go deeper though so there
there is other things that I want to
watch and weigh in on here's another one
he says he hates the sound of Asian
people learning English more than
someone listening to music on their
phone speaker from the same podcast
that's that's more annoying than any
other minority playing music at a
restaurant on their phone scare is
clearly trying to make a joke though
it's part of the same conversation -
which kind of like when you're cutting
up little bits of the conversation they
make it seem like worse mm-hmm
obviously trying to make a joke and I
and I agree it's not that funny
I agree with him he said that most I
mean that's really obscure I don't know
I've ever never heard that I don't alert
yes I have no idea what is I don't know
that you know hey there was um something
odd with the audio right there Oh should
I play it again uh no not yet just we're
gonna be working on fixing it right now
you can move on but I just wanna give
you a heads up
that's like when the doctor goes Brian
there's a Brian Regan joke joke he goes
he's at the eye doctor and he's like one
of your eyes is set a little bit lower
than the other one
there's nothing to do about it I just
want you to be self conscious thank you
Dan I'll do what I can
information he goes on and calls the
Democratic candidate
Andrew yang who as you well know is a
coveted member of the h3 nation who by
the way is up to seven percent after the
last debate in the way I might be able
to vote that's true
what's one right of every American
citizen to vote absolutely and to serve
on I know that's a responsibility he
called our boy Andrew yang a Jew [ __ ]
[ __ ] right which he was white vulgar I
don't know why he had to combine that
you and the [ __ ] but I mean it's like
it's like when you you know it was part
of a I listened to that clip it was part
of a wider discussion where he was
talking about Bernie being a Jew he's
like oh we got a Jew [ __ ] - referring
to yang yeah yeah I mean I'm
thinking about that if that's a funny
joke a Jude said I guess so cuz he's
math oriented
it's very racial but I guess andrew yang
makes the joke about himself that is
math so you're oriented Oz to the Jew
joke no I'm just trying to understand
thing yeah exactly
so what's the Jew part I didn't I don't
know be honest just that he's like at it
I think he just I think it's just funny
to mix up all the I mean in his mind
again speaking off-the-cuff and I have
to say as I look through this guy's work
this seems to be a reoccurring topic of
being kind of an edge Lord this is a
reoccurring theme about like kind of I'm
I'm off the rails
mm-hmm I'll say any [ __ ] thing so I
have a hard time thinking that SNL
didn't know more about this guy when
they hired him right but anyway let's
watch what he had to say about our boy I
don't know that's not an analogy don't
worry about that
Andrew yang [ __ ] Bernie Sanders Mario
Mario
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
they're like we're just a couple to
drinking beers and a living room we'll
say whatever the [ __ ] yes I bet you he
would never say drop the n-word he knows
good enough to not do that well as I was
saying he basically just I'll recap
that's fine you don't need to hear it
again
he was saying that he was just saying
Jude [ __ ] he was kept saying that a lot
he was referring to end to Bernie as a
Jew and then he said they're running a
Jew [ __ ] which would be Andrew yang who
I was telling you he was pulling at 7%
he's in fourth place I'm so happy to
hear that
yeah who's Jude [ __ ] now by the way
like what where does that word come from
what today yeah oh I think probably
around the when what was it like the
1900s a turn of the century there was a
ton of Chinese workers that came to
America to build like the railroads
across the country yeah who were just
like super [ __ ] had the worst
conditions ever and they were super like
marginalized and they called them chinks
probably they're making fun of the way
they sounded like ching chong ching
chong yeah it's rich it's definitely
racist but I don't see any you know it's
the problem and it's not even funny so
like the it just keeps using it and it's
not funny
and I agree like I understand trying to
be funny but like why does he keep using
it it seems like he keeps I think they
think it's funny they're all having a
laugh about it you know I agree with you
that it's not funny but there you have
it he keeps going we got the Jew [ __ ]
reference we've also got a video of him
doing a racist Asian voices all stuff to
service on Twitter these are all the
charges against him essentially that we
would like to review here this to NYC
grappling Krug NYC grappling club
grappling club NYC calm people
we're speaking like him now Thank You
graphic Rob oh by the way he didn't even
participate in this and I have to give
him credit funny why why don't like the
small [ __ ] they're too strong or
leotards as we call them oh man
god dammit sucks how much I look like
that kid but there you go it's a running
theme is what I'm trying to establish
here is that he and he associates other
comedians with him who are basically
they're things that they're shocking
that they're unrestricted and they could
see them throwing around the R word and
saying either you know they're insisting
on it they're kind of that that's the
vibe let's continue on has said on his
podcast he said on this podcast there's
only one way into Muslim heaven
you got a spill blood and praise a lot
by subpoenaing blood has referred to
women who disguised themselves as men to
find the Civil War as flat-chested
[ __ ] okay I mean we're really getting
into into the the mud here you could you
could do it right up on me that's a if
you're gonna take stuff from high here
and just like right oh no no no oh yeah
oh I'll never get a job that's why I'm
self-employed mm-hmm people go Ethan why
don't you want why don't you get a show
everyone tells me that I was like yeah I
know that talented so Ethan why don't
you get a shot go are you [ __ ]
kidding me some was gonna hire me said
that n-word said the artwork said I've
said everything I can't stay here on the
podcast and and I think you could easily
weaponize that against me
so my I don't know at what point do you
want to come to a conclusion
well we're thank you or keep us on track
here
he said about Sarah Silverman that
[Music]
whatever this is the way you know yada
yada yada he says later in the podcast
he criticized comedians who talked about
the depression and their Santa protein
calling them gay again with the edgy guy
thing those guys are [ __ ] gayer than
Isis he said well there's nothing gay
about Isis so I see he's just kind of
making a joke at least Isis is out there
we need to get [ __ ] after we blow
ourselves up we get a bunch of [ __ ]
these white fat hit comics they're like
I'm just sad life is hard and I'm gay I
think he's trying to be louis c.k but
like his way that's funny he's clearly
trying to be funny
but not my cup of tea
he also said Louis CK's his favorite
comedian so louis c.k is like i'll say
the most offensive [ __ ] but it works
because i'm like hilarious
you know louis c.k he never he didn't
even come famous till he was like almost
50 mm-hmm that's how long it takes to
actually get good at that type of brand
of humor so you know louis c.k could
have sounded just like this guy at his
age I mean who knows he used in the same
pause girls continue to make homophobic
comments using [ __ ] and other slurs
hey stop calling me [ __ ] gay dude I
ain't no quitter I mean okay whatever we
get the idea right so here here's my
here's my judge Ethan's about to weigh
in okay
by the way Andrew yang and him are a
conversation yang made a statement
saying I don't believe someone should
lose a job and be canceled for something
like this I think it's important that we
learn from it and move on and now that
he's been can andrew yang has set up the
conversation a sit-down with him
yang is gonna be President I saw someone
say it somewhere in the comments if yang
can bring YouTube comments together like
think about what it could do wow I don't
think he's a you know cuz think about it
is well let's not go on the okay and
yeah cuz I got the whole yang segment to
stay on track here he issued a cell pipe
in the music Zac as I make of as I make
my verdict now judge Ethan
has thought carefully about the
proceedings he judging thing is waiting
for his cinematic music before he issues
a verdict okay we can work on the music
a little bit for next time judging the
seventies like you know drama all stand
for judge Ethan judge Ethan is about to
pass his verdict now who stands before
you Shane Gilles comedian versus
Saturday Night Live
Shane is a young comedian known for his
no hold back attitude and for his edgy
brazen comedy he'll drop an R word an F
word a C word that's [ __ ] not [ __ ] for
clarity as judge Ethan clarity is number
one in this courtroom you see I used
both of those words in a way that I
thought was comedic ly appropriate and
not offensive do you think I succeeded
in that no no okay the verdict is
against me judge Ethan thank you good
night Saturday Night Live with any small
amount of vetting would have come to the
conclusion that this guy was an
offensive brand of humor had something
that was they saw something in this
young man that they thought would bring
an edge and a value to their show
Saturday Night Live they didn't
certainly knew about his history and his
brand of humor and it was only until the
Twitter mob came riding in like Gandalf
at the Battle of Helm's Deep but with
purple hair sort of white here and said
you shall not get this job mixing up
scenes the Lord of the Rings but you
could hear
and it was only then that the Twitter
blacklash struck that Center Night Live
pulled back Judge Ethan thinks that this
was improper because let's face it they
knew what they were getting themselves
into and I think we got to stop allowing
ourselves to be held prisoners to these
Twitter hate moms that guy's an
offensive comedian we knew that when we
hired him I mean what do you [ __ ]
stupid of course it's unlike every clip
like every [ __ ] clip of this guy's
like ching ching ching doo-doo-doo okay
let's give him a shot they said he's got
something but here we are now another
Twitter hate mob is taken out a young
man now is it funny
is it tasteful that's like debatable I
would I probably like his show I don't
like the song you know don't find him
funny but that's how people become
famous people like what they do and they
go to their shows and that's how like
you get bigger comedians because they're
funnier its buddy's trying well and he's
got a try but it's it's comedy like I
just don't think that you can judge
comedy like you judge other stuff
there's a difference between like a
secret recording of him being like man I
hate Chinese people you know you know
and then him on a podcast being
broadcast publicly trying to make jokes
comedy is a trial by fire you got to
throw it all on the line baby you put it
all out there and your bomb and you get
embarrassed and you get humiliated I've
experienced all those things myself
there's triumph there's defeat there's
humiliation you got to put it all on the
line and you and it's a trial by fire
you improve you need to see why your
pudding you see what works you figure
out who you are who your voice is if
people don't like it's not gonna work
and then you end up finding it one way
or another
ultimately if I would am I surprised
it's Saturday and I hired this guy I am
I am too but since they did they got and
they saw something in him they got a
[ __ ]
stick to their guns mm-hmm you know they
made the decision they put their foot
down and they said Shane you're out
you're in but then they said what you
don't think so all free deiay I [ __ ]
hate these Twitter mobs there so it's
like dude I agree but I don't know man I
think we should all defer to Andrew yang
on every topic I can tell you from our
experience I can see someone like taking
stuff the user that's what I'm saying
and writing like identical article so
the only difference is in my case it's
true and you weren't hired by us I know
that's true nobody hired me but my point
is that it's just not it's not fair this
is not gonna lead us anywhere good
egg-like hmm what's gonna become of this
podcast if he gets fired for that why
should we have a podcast we say Brandon
taken away though to be fair but they
hired him and now they're like forced to
fire him yeah they kind of like publicly
shamed of it ends up being like worse
for him right now yeah now he's like
like now he's blacklisted before he even
that's true
yeah like he got us any was before dude
he got his foot in the door it's so hard
to get on SNL as a young comedian he got
his foot in the door then they're like
oh actually this is your grave not your
door to opportunity
you know maybe though we'll see I mean
this probably raises his yeah exposure
level a tonton I mean I bet his podcast
popularity goes up now certainly
there'll be a counter support but
ultimately I think as a young comedian
he has to be funny enough to retain the
audience and I'm just not sure he is
that's up to him though but SNL is like
a you know - it's a proving ground
because let's face it that show [ __ ]
sucks dead yeah that's the other side of
my god holy crap so I it's like easy to
make fun of them but what they
so hard yeah I mean dude bro I mean I
would never attempt such a thing to do
an hour of sketch comedy live every week
its call me dude 97% of sketch comedy is
awful first of all horrible and then to
do it every week live I mean it's hard
to make that look good and then to make
it family-friendly too right even though
it's at 12 yeah but it's always like
very they do you can't say [ __ ] on SNL
and you most definitely certainly can't
say [ __ ] or mmm I'm kidding had you got
your pulse up there I loved it though
didn't I can i play with it though the
idea you know the boundary see sit was
me going hmm
like putting that like I was gonna say
oh you definitely can't Satan like is
that too much that's you kind of
following his is that tasteful it's just
not that funny it's not it's not fine
does anyone back there think it's funny
because he was laughing man well I feel
like Ethan judge Ethan has weighed in
and has closed the book on that one I
mean look I gotta be comfortable I don't
know what to tell you gila manspreading
look at you well show my feet even show
it like can you understand that
I'm totally on my side and he's on my
side some real exposure what are you an
investigative journalist I either would
you like to make a bow in a man spray
Kareem said Chris Hansen would like to
talk to you all about it yang is being
ignored we do not like this there's a
very political show yank is being
ignored
Andrew gang the the [ __ ] Jew as we like
to call him here on the agency podcast
no that's not that see what's that funny
cuz it was a call back there's a call
back
it's a little different but somebody
could cut that and then my career is
over there you go and you yank friend of
the show I'm supporter I have
contributed to his campaign 100 dollars
in full disclosure I want to be upfront
with you guys yank 2020 yeah in game I
want to show you guys so yang has been
growing in the polls like for so long
look at this [ __ ] and there's like this
whole thread about how the media is
crazy how they they continue to ignore
him here look at this I love this photo
yang is at at this point like 4% mm-hmm
where the [ __ ] is he there's space for
another face here it wouldn't be perfect
he's above O'Rourke and this phantom
undecided only 2.2 percent that's not a
lot that many people made up their mind
a lot of people are not that strongly
committed to their current choice so and
then here this was from the most recent
debate I know this from the first debate
yank 2 minutes you know it's funny you
yang had such an impression on that
first debate he made every minute count
every minute was so impactful Biden
spent 40 minutes saying [ __ ] nothing
dude by the way all these people are out
Bennet Gillibrand Hickel Dubrow with the
name like Hickenlooper when you
Hickenlooper your way on out of here
SWA well and Williamson all-out yank
he's at 7% California on a poll that
just came out today is that [ __ ]
crazy here new Iowa poll Joe Biden leads
the pack look at this you notice anyone
missing it's like it's it's it's it's
wild the contenders they're like sorry
there just wasn't space somehow on the
bottom row but it would fit perfectly
exactly they
the bottom row to leave out one spot man
and these are some [ __ ] here that I
ain't never even heard of in my life a
lot of attention is gonna be on that
Bernie Sanders Joe Biden dynamic and
then of course those other candidates
you know folks you look again who else
is on that stage with the former vice
president with Bernie Sanders you know
Andrew yang Chris that's so good oh man
nice coat so let's see MSNBC another one
yang is coming in again at like 2 or 3
percent here you go there's just not
enough space for yang he's coming he's
really growing in the polls man when he
came on here he was pulling around 2
percent and he's really growing here's
another one NBC again it's like dude he
doesn't exist to these media people it's
crazy it's like wait what was it that
positive Twitter mentions oh that's very
complimentary positive Twitter meant
that means that 60% the 61% of people
that mentioned O'Rourke are talking [ __ ]
about Bernie Sanders Wow 66% of people
that mentioned Sanders on Twitter a
talking [ __ ] and Biden coming in at a
whopping 69 percent of the people
talking about Biden are talking [ __ ]
about him I congratulate her
congratulations to Rorick you know it's
funny I thought Trump he tweeted out
some celebratory message about how he's
at fifty percent approval rating I was
like bro if I get 50 percent on a test
that's a [ __ ] F that's like a [ __ ]
ass that's like a hardcore fail but
there you go that's the way it is that's
the way our world is you know welcome to
democracy it ain't pretty
[Music]
here thanks for accepting our invite to
speak to our audience today
here's live footage of Bernie here she's
talking to yang they invited him on the
[ __ ] show to talk about like mass
shootings for something you know that's
what they're showing the footage up is
that good or what I was that was spicy
spicy good good good
let's see anyway you get the idea it
goes on and on and on and on and on it's
crazy this thread it's got it all there
was a recent one
NBC referring to him as John yang now
this is one he tweeted out John yang
Kraus deserves this was just recently
didn't get his name John yang the [ __ ]
you gotta know his name ain't John and
then on the newest debates he was coming
in at like five four than he's up to 7%
now the newest debates look how much
time he spent talking this just happened
like a couple of nights ago he's falling
higher than all these people mm-hmm
where did you say he was pulling the at7
I just saw today in California he's
pulling at 7% he's in fourth place dude
it wasn't freaky he passed Harris he's
in fourth place isn't that crazy
it was crazy it's good it's exciting but
I'll tell you what I think yang strategy
is to talk as little as possible
because these guys drone on and on they
say the same dumb [ __ ] they fight to
speak over it's all just I mean it's
it's worthless they all look about
we they just end up looking so like
petty arguing it's just boring it's
empty words always and when yang speaks
he speaks with purpose and clarity and
and I think that you know in a sense he
likes being marginalized like this it
gives him the underdog story so it might
be a very strategic and intelligent
thing he's doing here you know can I get
an amen
Gila hey man that's all I have about
that that's all I have to say about that
can I send Ohio real quick gunfire
that's the best that's the best way to
like someone's life up hire and fire
them well I've got it the KFC I've got
the KFC dating app dating sim game and I
really I don't even want to give them
the satisfaction but it's like it's so
bizarre what is going on with KFC's
marketing really watch the [ __ ] mind I
can see maybe I shouldn't show too much
of it and walk this worldwide less than
wait what
Oh for the for the music yeah a good
point
it was um G last time to be fair not
actually case yeah but let's watch it I
think the animation prefix I kind of
want to watch this anime I kind of want
[ __ ] the colonel all right I'm in let's
go to KFC why is it so good
dude so like what what is going on with
their marketing department man
they already did the whole thing with
the CGI like hipster KFC dude you know
they seem to be trying to push like
[ __ ] Colonel yeah they want yet yes
exactly
we don't want a colonel that needs a
colonoscopy we want us we want a colonel
that's gonna give you a colonoscopy with
this [ __ ] right ela nope
so here it is guys September 24th I'm
afraid it's gonna be good cuz the
graphics are sick but their food sucks
don't forget that have I just played
into their hands cuz I really don't have
anything to say except that the
animation looks really good is there
gonna be nudity I mean how far do these
dating sims go that's a good question I
mean some of them get pretty raunchy I
think is there a rating rated them you
know do you know be sick if he served
you like a bucket and his [ __ ] was in it
and said chicken yeah yeah
he's holding the puck and he's like yeah
baby tell me the right things what is
going on at KFC seriously well I was
gonna talk about this but I thought you
had a hotter take on this Yili me cuz
you were like yeah I thought you only
why I was just so confused why don't
they have a video game but I agree and
they the graphics look good actually
it's just so confusing let me read some
of the dialogue ever since we were
little babies playing together and you
rescued me from that quicksand box it's
been clear to me that you're the most
loving caring person I know you're gonna
do great
[ __ ] you this is awful so those titties
will damn its Ashlyn whoa look how they
spelled her name your archrival Ashley
oh just spell
she's totally evil but you can't help
but be filled with jealousy she can't
get anything she wants and she knows it
anything for a fellow chef a daughter
[ __ ] a dog sick
professor dog steps in to settle the
class down and set some ground rules
yeah I'm not gonna continue on with this
[ __ ] okay well there you go Colonel you
got your advertising we got a new
Lincoln ad by Matthew McConaughey you
know I'm a fan of this shed I love him
I just love McConaughey performance
comes in lots of flavors selling cars
there's the amp up over tuned feeding
frenzy of sheet metal kind right and
then there's performance that just
leaves you feeling better as a result
Ian that's the guy Lincoln's about
that's the kinda becoming creepy yeah
he's becoming like the character from
true detectives that he's hunting yeah
I kind of want this car that's in the
smoke performance comes in lots of
flavor comes in lots of flavors
there's the amp up over tuned feeding
frenzy of sheet metal kind what what he
left it behind that just leaves you
feeling better as a result that's the
guy Lincoln's about did I
guaran-fucking-tee all my heart and soul
that Matthew McConaughey doesn't drive a
link in the Lincoln is like the lamest
car you can buy am i right do I have a
wrong person
22 million views on this it doesn't need
to drive it in my fan to be in a
commercial but I know but he's he's
pitching it if you're gonna have someone
like Matthew McConaughey selling
Lincoln's you're like dude you don't
drive a Lincoln coz he's he's pitching
it like this is the car yeah I like that
you know do you see this 22 million
views probably probably just cuz they
paid for it yeah there's a lot do you
guys agree that Lincoln's are just like
it's kind of a just an old person car
right yeah yeah I mean it is a luxury
brand I'm sure
I mean Matthew McConaughey's probably
has a few cars you know what I mean he's
probably got a Lincoln or two they
probably gave him only so he could say
you have one yeah it's probably good I
just looked it up there is a website
that's dedicated to what cars
celebrities drive
oh I don't no idea how accurate this is
but it does say that he owns a Lincoln
but then he also owns a bunch of Camaros
which yeah Camaro is Chevy and their
competitors yeah they're competitors so
yeah that's what I thought [ __ ] about
Lincoln sees he hands out with the new
video this is that big fun time portion
of the podcast it's probably not gonna
get claimed but look at this mother this
is the biggest watermelon I want a
[ __ ] watermelon that big he's got uh
he take he takes the top off
he puts like a juice blender in it and
some damn knobs it mixes it up with ice
puts the top back on and wouldn't you
know this crazy Turkish chef has got
watermelon juice filling up a whole
goddamn
sure this crazy goofy smiling he kind of
looks like Turkish benches fear of him
being honest
except much happier much happier now now
he cut him open up a water money's
putting all kinds of fruits apple honey
milk pistachios are you've taken the
soup bar now ice
you got that blender in their industrial
baby looks like you could clear a septic
tank with that thing and a pump dude I
mean this guy's not from another level
that's probably really good I'm I you
this guy's really something isn't he
it's funny how he's adopted the the
smiling through the camera thing you
know he keeps taking it further and like
he just smiles to the camera he did one
recently where he wasn't smiling and
everyone was concerned about it and he
just looked really sad and all I can do
that me try to find that since I'm here
was funny I was thinking of pulling it
to keep tabs on him if he ever like does
a celebrity chef those dates we got a
hmm
well this one censored what the hell Oh
cuz he's like burning full carcasses I
gotta find the one where he's not oh
[ __ ] oh sick no no he's fine he's all
happy here where's the one where he's
not happy dude it's oh look at his face
eight million views everyone's worried
about this guy dude this one's trippy
watch he just decided not to smile yeah
look at that mug man
it's almost threatening when he doesn't
smile in it there was a face yeah that's
you know you know pay your bill you know
look at him he looks so sad it doesn't
it doesn't work if he's not I wasn't
feeling it that day or something that's
the deal
but the visas are there you know so I'm
Feliz what he's cooking it's like a mash
he's got some steaks does this guy ever
work in the restaurant I wonder because
he's always in back doing some crazy
[ __ ] I assume somebody's running the
restaurant
we've had some Turkish fans email about
him and he's very well-known in Turkey
dude this has 8 million views his
restaurant sir but man that looks crazy
well I hope he's ok I don't know why he
wasn't smiling on that day the way the
fans have described him is it honestly
it kind of sounds like the way we think
about guy here he's kind of their guy
fieri because he's kind of like a joke
there mm-hmm
no make sense I love him I would totally
eat at his restaurant his food looks
amazing
he's a really common chef thing this guy
he's really creative he's out there
doing all this crazy [ __ ]
he's got a damn smile too well he's no I
mean what more could you ask for in life
usually we've got the Guinness records
but I think weed that's everything let's
just save that and get the [ __ ] out of
here well I'm gonna get cancelled now
and I'm gonna be in New York so
hopefully we'll ruin my trip to New York
awesome you guys are leaving tonight huh
Alex exam exam so tomorrow because
you're gonna have to be upper that's
going to I hate flying in New York it's
like the time switch the five hours plus
the three hour time switch is just the
right amount to [ __ ] your whole life up
you know yep well we are seeing Hamilton
yeah and we're gonna go get a nice
dinner with Jon we got the fan meetup on
Friday and we're gonna meet your mom yes
and my sister been to New York before my
sister had a baby just three months
before me so where the beep the babies
are gonna meet each other
babes are gonna meet look honey he looks
like Theodore but Israeli you know it's
pretty funny that's it so hopefully
we'll see you guys on Friday let me give
you a dressing but it's in the
description if you are curious to join
us
107 Grand Street New York New York
the pop-up is all weekend Friday
Saturday Sunday we will be there on
Friday at 11 o'clock and we would be
there for probably four hours we'll try
to endure for as long as we can because
we love meeting you guys and you know
get out there and shake our dicks touch
dicks
put my dick in your hand and then you
can describe it to Ben Shapiro I was
thinking of making a tweet like I can
describe bench Piero's penis message me
media outlets I have credible
accusations against beneficiary I can
describe his penis Derek go ahead ask me
what is the inch beers penis look like
no that's not I'll tell you you already
you've already been hired and fired like
twice during this episode I'll tell you
what if Ben Spiros penis looks like off
there but I have an accurate description
I can draw it for you okay go ahead and
cue the music then it's going well guys
thank you so much we will not be here on
Friday because we'll be in New York but
we wish you all the best week the best
week and the best times the best friends
the best laughs the best goofs the best
times baby save that money use it
responsibly save for your future it's
important you know peace of mind is
everything you know a bird in the hand
is better than two in the bush that's
what Benjamin Franklin said and all
humans of us the diplomat that really
polish so take care of yourself out
there you know not you then who write
ela that's right not you then who take
care of your body eat right meditate
talk to a doctor a therapist take
medicine if you need to you know what
I'm saying like if you got and take care
of yourself cuz who was going to do it
thanks for watching everybody
pouring see you next week
[Music]